well of course last night the golden
knights did it
again vegas clinching their second round
series at home by winning
four straight games now the focus turns
to montreal
and the stanley cup semifinals john
treach live in studio with more from the
vegas general manager
a happy one indeed brian when vegas
general manager kelly mccrimmon
was a kid in the great white north the
montreal canadiens were his country's
most
sacred institution now he leads a team
deep in the american desert trying to
crush canada's last
hockey hope and he knows the secret
weapon is the electric home environment
t-mobile arena is not for the hockey
purist it's part playoff passion part
pool party and 100 percent invested the
golden knights changed the course of the
series in game three when they came from
behind to win
and then win again in game four and last
night's game six the two teams traded
goals but
colorado was cold clocked by the energy
and grit of the golden knights
and their ambiently awesome fan base it
was a powerful
even for a hockey lifer
just unbelievable it really is and it's
it's not just the the volume but it's
the it's the vibe and the energy
that you that you feel i think that both
our series against minnesota our series
against uh
colorado they made a difference they
they
contributed to our team winning the game
you know let's be honest down two
nothing coming back to
coming back to vegas for game three if
you don't win game three
probably that hill's too steep to uh to
then climb against a team that good
yeah the startling sounds of game day
could impact montreal even more because
of
the 14-day canadian quarantine laws
there will be no traveling fans from
canada
at t-mobile arena the canadians may pump
computer-generated noise into their own
arena but
oh the flurry chance from the people
raining down on them
will hit differently